if it's a math equation
what does the final
calculation look like in terms of ending
up in heaven what does it mean to live a
good
life in the end is it
um the average madison you do is is low
can you are you allowed to make mistakes
yeah uh you know the the the metric is
love
right and love is not a feeling it's an
act of the will to will the good of the
other that's aquinas again to will the
good of the other as other and see
that's the anti-black hole principle
when i
i don't wield the good of the other as
others because if i'm willing you're
good because it's good for me so uh
again you know it's good for you that
i'm on this program i guess i'm willing
you're good but that's cause it's gonna
be down to my benefit right that's just
an indirect egotism
that's why i see love is really rare and
strange that i really want
what's good for you
as other
so not connected to the black hole
tendency of my own prideful ego when
i've broken that
i've forgotten self and i've moved into
the space of your own good that's what
love is now god wants us to be you know
by this they will know that you're my
disciples that you love one another
jesus says so that's it
now i mean life is
ups and downs and back and forth and
we're better or worse at that
the point of the church is to graft us
onto christ that we might become more
and more conformed to love but you know
the final calculus i'll leave that to
god i mean like but but use love as the
metric at the end of the day when you
examine your conscience
did i will the good of the other today
how how effective was i at that
and and be just like ignatia viola be
brutally honest or was i just willing
someone's good because it was good for
me
uh what where where were those moments
where i was like the dog on the beach
yeah see see and see play it the way not
so much god the lawgiver surveying and
you did you know three of those and four
it's god wants us to be fully alive
saint irenaeus is one of my great heroes
ancient you know patristic figure and
his famous line is gloria day homo
vivens right the glory of god
is a human being fully alive
see and that gets us over this sort of
obsession with legalism and did i do
enough and is that that's a big enough
sin and
god wants us fully alive the key to that
is willing the good of the other he he
died
that we might come to a richer
appropriation of that so to be fully
alive
is to be in love with the world or to
love the world
deeply and what love means is the other
is get out of yourself right it's it's
it's the humility yeah getting out of
yourself
that somehow is not
uh that's not even selfless because uh
the word selfless requires her to be
yourself
it's it's almost like just letting go
you might talk about like a gift of self
that you you're self aware but you you
give a gift of yourself
yourself becomes not a magnet drawing
things into itself but it becomes a
radiant source of life for others like
mother teresa would have had a keen
sense of herself it seems to me but it
was um
to light other people uh up so that they
might be uh radiant
you know that's the game so you you
probably articulate it that way too
yeah
i love love it's such an interesting
thing but we have to be hard-nosed about
it like you know your friend dostoyevsky
that love is a harsh and dreadful thing
right it's not a feeling and our culture
is so sentimentalized love that it's
having warm feelings or doing what
people want and that's not it at all
love is always correlated to the order
of the good
because if i'm willing the good of the
other i have to know what that good is
right yeah so a parent that says i'll
give the kid whatever she wants well
that's not love that's that's indulgence
or that's sentimentality
but i have to know what the goods really
are if i'm going to will them for you
right yeah i in some sense
you're absolutely right a component of
love is the struggle to know the other
right it's this struggle to understand i
mean that's um that's what i mean by
empathy it's the yeah it's not it's yeah
it's not valentine's day romantic gifts
it's uh it's a struggle it's like uh
trying to understand trying to perturb
your own mind and that of another human
being to try to figure out who they are
what they want what makes them uh
happy what are they afraid of what are
they hoping for and it's like a dance
right dance of conversation a dance of
uh just
shared experiences and all that kind of
stuff and all of that requires for you
to be
i guess um
yeah empathize
imagine
yourself
in their place
and then love that person when you're
living inside that person yeah
several minutes ago about the pillars of
christianity so we talked about god talk
about incarnation but you're getting now
to a third key one namely the trinity
because
we're monotheists right but we don't
think god is monolithically one we think
god is a play of persons
and the father from from
all eternity
by a great mental act
forms his interior word as aquinas puts
it and that's the law gauss right that's
the verb that's the word by which the
father knows himself and we call that
the sun so the imago it's the image of
the father but then see the great thing
is that imago is not like just a dead
image on a mirror or a dead image at a
pond or something it's
it's a full
reflection of the father's being
he's one in being with the father
therefore the son has everything the
father has except being the father but
that means that the two of them look at
each other
and they're just crazy in love with each
other because
the the father is the fullness of being
the son is the fullness of being and
they're so crazy in love with each other
that they this is um fulton she put it
this way that there's this
they just they love each other with this
sigh
and we call that the spiritual song to
us that's the holy breath right the holy
sigh of love between the father and the
son
and that's there's one being one essence
we say of god but in these three persons
but all your language about like dance
and play and community
the greek fathers talked about perry
coraces which means god the three
persons kind of sit in a choir together
so they they um they sing together
you know
and and that's why see
christianity is unique in this claim
that god
is love so every religion will say god
loves you know in some way love is an
attribute of god
god is or love is a thing that god does
sometimes but christianity is unique in
all the religions in saying that god is
love
you